if you were an
evil individual record executive that
wanted to create a system that could
extract as much wealth from the artists
that you possibly could given the
technology that exists right now
MH how would it look easy money okay um
you create somebody who is the most
radical
Persona an image of counterculture
Counter Culture as possible and feed
them hits that's it like think about
example like so so like me and boogas
talk about this all the time which
is I think at its corol I think Hip Hop
is Black Culture right and I think
you've heard from a lot of different
perspectives within the Black Culture
you've heard from the CEO right a Jay-Z
which also drug you've heard from The
Artsy dude Kanye you've heard from a
stripper you've heard from the it's like
what's the next extreme thing that you
haven't heard from yet what's the next
extreme perspective you haven't heard
from yet get that look at sexy red I
think sexy red just gonna say that name
I think sexy red is I don't subscribe to
this like it's like a weapon of mass D
destruction I just think like it's the
natural progression of things it's like
sexy red
is I think represents the authenticity
that everyone else is almost trying to
push she's like the real deal she's the
real thing and that's why it resonates
cuz it's like oh very very small
percentage of the culture very small but
it's but but it's impactful but it's
impact and it's authentic and so
interesting look at like the progression
of the game right it's like okay but
where do you go after sexy red
at some point me and Bo talk about this
all the time at some point you're going
to hear you've heard from the CEO you've
heard from the drug dealer you've heard
from the stripper you've heard from the
this at some point you'll hear from the
crackhead you'll hear from the this
you'll hear [__] you will why would it
stop at you're making you're making a
point think about it why would it stop
here you're right cuz you just get more
exhausted men that's why women have been
making the best music it's like think
about it bro like we're not stopping
here
it's going to go to the next and then
the next and then the next and then it's
more extreme oh yeah bro give it 10
years a crack a legitimate like where
it's like clear that that's their brand
will have a number one song in the world
and it is a known crackhead and we will
be living in a Black Mirror episode
where everyone is rooting and cheering
on for the train wreck of a of a c what
was the first thing you said though you
said counterculture right yeah and
counterculture is anything that goes
almost completely against whatever the
mainstream popularity is well and what
in my correct me if I'm wrong the
culture of Hip Hop at its core and at
its Inception was intelligent movement
what's the antithesis of intelligent
movement crackhead being Reckless
Reckless okay we're like kind of close
well no no to your point I want to
everything right now like why why the
old heads are like hip hop is dying is
because what is happening is
counterculture to the cult of Hip Hop's
Inception yeah okay the [__] happening
in Hip Hop is actually Counter Culture
in the culture is hip-hop to The Counter
Culture I'm curious about this
okay hip-hop I don't think had a number
one album last year right until whatever
it was yeah uh there is a form of music
that has
gained I saw this popular and I sent it
to the group chat it was so spot on I'm
curious your take on it and is country
this Rebellion that you're talking about
is this this Counter Culture if the
mainstream culture of everybody's
listening to hip-hop and Hip-Hop is it
might not be representative of every
single person in America but it is
popular music now is Country Now the
most rebellious or counterculture thing
to hip-hop and is that why it's become
so popular I think this I think it's I
think it's not that black and white but
I think there's a couple things I think
it happened with rock music which
is subject matter in rock music reached
the ceiling where we had heard
everything yeah and I think with rap we
have heard everything oh you're also
sliding on and op heard that in fact I
heard it and it was better you're
selling drugs I heard that 50 did it and
it was way harder you're sad you're
emotional you're sad heard that cuy way
better right wa you know what I'm saying
it's like everything that's happening in
rap I've already heard the better
version of it so what haven't we heard
yet so what so so it's reached this
point of we've heard all this it's like
at this sort of breaking point where
what's about to happen and that's one
layer of it I think the other layer is
people who listen to country and rock
they weren't on the streaming platforms
at first they were still on iTunes yeah
right they were still buying CDs they
were still buying CDs they've migrated
they've migrated over where now my dad
is on Spotify see what I'm saying that
was the last of music that was still so
now you're getting the audience that was
basically country music's audience in my
opinion was last to migrate to streaming
but now that they have people are seeing
that wow there's a lot of them H think
about so it's not
necessarily there it's just that they
were the last ones to convert and
because of the conversion of migration
now we're seeing these numbers that look
astronomical but those were always the
[__] numbers they were always there
that's interesting they were always
there been moving yeah they were always
there they were just last their own
award show that was huge they were just
last to the party is all that happened
in my opinion but also I do think rap's
subject matter has reached a ceiling
where there's no New Perspectives being
introduced outside of like the select
few which is why like I know a lot of
people had Flack for Kendrick's most
recent album but in my opinion father
time is like one of the greatest songs
released in the past 10 years because
I've never heard a mainstream rapper
talk about and I could be wrong right I
don't want to like say that this is the
God's honest truth but it's like I just
have never heard a mainstream rapper
talk about father issues in that light I
thought it was [__] profound I've
heard mother issues and all that or
child abuse he talk child yeah it's like
I think
introducing new um Concepts into the
Lexicon of rap is powerful and if you
don't like the sound of it that's fine
that's fair that's taste but I respect
that and that's why I did Santiago was
because honestly like Kendrick's album
and really Father Time inspired me to
speak on my issues because I was like oh
you know oh so it's safe to do that and
then I think I also like talked about
[__] that's never been talked about
before and this is all forms of art once
people see that it can be done they feel
way more comfortable doing it themselves
as well they just can't conceptualize
talking about like an abusive childhood
or a relationship with their parents
which they might also have but there's
too they're too locked in this game of
how can I replicate what's successful
once you make something else successful
they start going well I would also like
to try to do that the labels are hanging
on by a threat I'll tell you this wait
who whoa whoa whoa the labels are not
going to allow rap to Fall by the
wayside like that they're going to keep
boosting and juicing the stream so that
it appears that what are yall talking
about rap's not losing steam there's
country sure but we're still crushing no
you're not wow you're having to spend a
lot of money to keep up the facade This
Is A Star is Born what is the Lady Gaga
movie it's that Star is Born yeah it's
it's right now the labels are doing
everything they can to keep the makeup
and the wig and the choreography going M
so that it looks like [__] is popping
but it's not it's not and how does how
does that end do they run out of money
no I think it's like every genre I think
I think bro to be honest once again what
this is the truth is boring right here's
the truth you know what it is four years
ago every CEO was signing every
SoundCloud rapper in their cousin you
know what they're about to do sign every
country artist and their cousin and
guess what the country artist like we
talked about before they'll make enough
money to cover the loss of the rappers
that they're still Froning M and so it
doesn't matter it'll always look like a
rap's still doing its thing country's
booming yeah but rap is still crushing
yeah but y'all are signing the country
artist I know because I'm talking to the
[__] I saw relationships with the
people at the labels and some of them
are are are good people and we talk
about it all the time where it's like
their whole focus is country artists huh
my theory is the whole focus is look at
Morgan Wallen bro are you kidding well
he some words ra use bro Morgan Wallen
bro Morgan Wallen jelly roll shout out
Jelly that's the man Bailey Zimmerman
like all these dudes who are like dudes
and women who are coming through this
vessel of this singer songwriter country
twang alternative sort of space that's
who the labels are scooping up like they
were doing six years ago with like Lil
TJ and Polo G and all those kind of guys
it's like that's what they're on now
that's it's musical chairs bro it's like
thinking that these people actually give
a [__] about you is the mistake now now
now real quick if rap starts to let's
say struggle and Views and streams are
harder to come by yeah do you think that
rappers will resort to more extreme
tactics in order to Garner those views
or streams and that's how the art
becomes the crackhead doing all these
crazy things or the slide on the Ops
gets even crazi I need to do something
even crazier in order to get the
reaction that I did before yes but also
it's like labels I think labels are
going to this right here you got
something L CH uh yeah you got it get
a I think um labels are going to
continue to prop up rap to attract
newcomers
MH because put it like this right labels
letting rap fall is a bad idea for them
because now where the upand cominging
rapper is going to go to they're going
to feel like well no I'm not going to go
over there I'm not going to sign because
all these rappers are falling off but if
you keep seeing rappers doing crazy
numbers you're like all right so there's
still a place for us so they're going to
keep propping it up knowing deep down
damn we're having to spend 30 grand
every four weeks to keep all these
rappers popped up but these country
artists are making millions but you know
what at least we're still recruiting and
and uh and persuading these upand
cominging rappers to come over here and
they want to keep the rappers so they
don't lose like market share yeah of
course m al you
don't this is this is a fact I might
even get I don't know my lawyer will
probably call me after this but when I
left Colombia first of all I bought
myself out of the deal um because what
does that mean it means they wanted
another album yeah right um and I said
I'm not doing another album I said okay
well we need money this is like layman
terms like all right cool here's a
million in some change y'all can have
it and also part of that was well we
want market share on your first 20 songs
or whatever the [__] it was that you put
out independent what do I give a flying
[__] about y'all's little dick measuring
contest in the industry meaning those
songs meaning like after I leave the
label when I put out 20 songs
independently and hit Daily Double puts
out the market share report where umg
has 30% Sony has 20 the Sony wanted to
be able to claim my first 20 or whatever
songs independently as part of their
market share even if they're not with
Sony that was what do I give a [__]
about y'all's weird dick measuring
contest that you can that you can Flex
to the other [__] weird CEO at the
Christmas party I don't give a flying
[__] I'm getting out of here you know
what I'm saying but it's like like
that's what they're moving off of is
market share yes cuzz bonuses are
attached with that if you're number one
in maret maret share get a bigger check
yeah you as the CEO or whatever of
course so my theory with uh music genres
is that any new music genre it's going
to have its Spike yeah and then it's
going to level out people say Rock is
Dead Rock's not dead it's just smaller
yeah they still rock stations people
still no no I don't know if I don't
think it booms again I think it just
levels out so it's like right now we're
in the country boom yeah and it's going
to level out I just think Hip Hop has
leveled out we have now we have afro
Beats is a new of mus that
heard I want to say so many hot
takes country is not new country's been
around for no but I know what he's
saying but I know what you're saying new
to like streamers and no just like new
to the marketplace this is the being
this is the first time since streaming
boom where country was cool to young
people yes fair enough but to that point
I think
um I think we're once again this is this
is a
this is really me holding up a mirror CU
I'm white so like I feel I can speak on
this white people white people and white
boys and and white chicks with the
colleges and sororities and
fraternities so enamored by Black
Culture right M and for a while and for
a while it went from like I remember
being in high school and there was
pockets of like the goth chicks and
people who they listened to like a
certain kind of music there's people
listening to like you know I went to
high school 06 I was a freshman 2010 I
graduated 20 minutes outside of Atlanta
so like Snap music and D4L and Soulja
Boy came and performed at the peper
rally and so it was like that era it's
like there was the people who were
listening to that and and whatever I
think now what's happened with rap is
that the people who would have been
listening to goth music and Goth artists
and punk you know artists whether it was
Chemical Romance or whatever it
was here's Lil Pete here's World here
hip hop gave every genre a
representative ah but now what's
happening the pendulum has swung where
it's like you know
what I think I would just rather listen
to Just The Goth artist or just the
country artist not the country hip-hop
mix not the goth hip-hop
mix there's enough art like it just it
just it's time right it's time where
it's like it was all hip-hop dominated
we got to really think right it's been
2024 it's been 10 11 12 years since like
trap boomed and it was a complete
insurgence and takeover right where rap
and and and mainly the production of rap
and the trap influence was in everything
Ariana gr was putting out albums that
had trap high hats you feel me it's like
you got the biggest pop stars in the
world using hip-hop influence in 808 and
[__] like that so I I just think now
enough time has passed where people are
like oh it starts with the artist where
it's like you know what I think I just
want to make like some punk
Punk pop goth [__] some [__] Boys
Like Girls Chemical Romance allamerican
reject [__] like I just want to do that
and then the same people who were
listening to maybe like the emo version
of hip-hop are like oh you know what it
was really this that I was looking for
this just wasn't there in 2014 but now
it is there and I think I just think
that that's what's happening it's just
it's becom a l more nuanced in their
yeah it's becoming a lot
compartmentalized yeah it's like if you
want pop punk emo [__] there's actually
pop punk emo bands that can just fulfill
that role and if you want trap rap
there's that yeah I think the past 10
years rap just bled over to everything
and so it was massive and now I think
you have people like the Noah KH who are
singer song writers and the and the
Lizzy maau pin or whatever her name is
she's [__] incredible and and just
you know Luke Bryan and Morgan wallins
and Bailey just all these people who who
occupy real estate that maybe five years
ago belonged to rap fans there was an
overlap but now it's just very clear to
those same fans that actually this is
just what I wanted Morgan Wallen blew up
right and I think within a year or two
not Morgan Wallen Noah Khan that song
stick season it's [__] incredible
sold out Benway Park wow really yes like
I think two nights in a row jeez J Wow
and it's like Fenway Park but like you
say the name Noah KH in a hip-hop space
nobody knows I don't know I don't know
who know you heard the song you but
stick season is [__] incredible
they're also probably not buying as many
fake stream but you know num you know
what to me to me bro like you never know
never know I'm just so passionate about
is not reflected I'm so passionate about
great music yeah and I think that is
what we'll always win yeah is is great
music and I think a lot of artists and a
lot of people that get caught up in why
things aren't working why is hip-hop
failing why is this you know what the
greats are always going to be fine the
greats are always the greats are always
going to be fine the people who were
never that ill will always fall off
sorry this is not related to what you
said but I just didn't want to forget it
can you talk about industry plants a
little bit like I hear that term a lot
yeah what does that even mean I don't
even know what it means you know what
that means to people and it's so funny
because the prerequisite years ago used
to be you had to be an industry plan and
what industry plant means is basically
like we only know you because the
industry planted you here well that used
to be the only way you could be
known yeah think about it right it's
like the first time I heard jcole was 09
on blueprint 3 On A Star is Born I
remember I bought blueprint 3 and cu's
debut on the same day September 9th I
think 09 right September 13th something
like that that was the first time I
heard J.Cole then I heard the warmup and
it was a rap and I was a fan he was an
industry plant by industry plant
standards because first time I hear he
was on a JayZ album that's a crazy I
think he was already signed to but it's
like that used to be I grew up in Queens
and he went to St John's I believe and
he was like I saw him handing out right
so you were like early in that way but
it's like it's like you used to only be
able to find out about artists if the
industry pushed that yeah and then the
internet opened up and a lot of this
like organic rise gorilla movements
happened to the point where it was very
clear like if you blew up via internet
and gorilla style or if like an industry
put put you there and so it started this
conversation of nah you're not as real
as them and you know and for me it's
like it it used to [__] with me a lot to
be honest people call me an industry
plan because discredits all the work you
did yeah bro cuz I am
the furthest thing from from it and if
like and I get mad because I'm like one
discredits the work but two I'm like
damn bro like y'all are missing out on
so much
inspiration do you understand that like
if you actually realize the truth that
you would realize you can do it too yeah
you know what I'm saying it's like bro
they want the justification for why they
didn't do it they don't want to know how
they'd rather not do the work and have
an excuse yeah and it yeah BR it's part
of the Neo baby he's on cuz he cheated
not because you're nice right and you it
worked and you figured out the system
and you did that your had money so it
actually doesn't count what you did yeah
and it bro used to bother the [__] out
of me cuz I prided myself on that it was
a part of my identity was my come up you
know what I mean like damn y'all about
it like especially it came during a time
where they were taking away everything
else it felt like I was like damn y'all
taking away that too like that was the
thing that was like Teflon like wait
y'all saying this now what were they
saying and I remember the dude who
started the rumor straight up and I'm
cool with him now what rumor what what
were they saying so the rumor was it
started on Kanye to the it was a forum
yeah right and the Rumor was my dad
worked for columia oh and that's how I
got on first of all none of that makes
sense right it's like so then why did I
have to put out 11 mixtapes yeah oh so
he conveniently got hired after the 11th
mixtape it's like okay that's priz
pi.com guys and if you use the promo
code Schultz they will match your
initial deposit up to $1 so you put up
100 you get 100 for free why don't you
gamble with100 free dollars prix.com now
let's get back to the show